-You got a bulldog named Tank.
-I did. I did.
And here´s a picture Tank.
Adorable.
-Oh, she is so sweet.
-And how is life with Tank?
You did not have Tank last time
you were here.
-I didn´t.
It took me a while to get Tank.
-Mm-hmm, ´cause you were -- why?
-I don´t know.
I was procrastinating.
-Was it someone else´s dog?
[ Laughter ]
-I was worried.
I was worried about
an animal in my home.
-Sure.
So -- but I got Tank,
and she´s really --
she´s an odd dog.
I mean, she´s as odd as you
would imagine her to be, my dog.
-Why -- oh, your --
because it´s your dog?
-I guess so.
I don´t know.
I mean -- I don´t know.
[ Light laughter ]
-That´s true.
I wouldn´t expect --
-But she´s very --
she´s very vocal.
-Vocal. Now, a dog --
do you mean they´re barking
a lot?
-Yes.
She barks a lot,
but she makes --
she makes really weird noises.
-She makes weird noises?
-Yeah, I think she --
she´ll be like, she kind of
talks a little bit to me.
-You brought a video.
Are you gonna --
should we try to hear what
you think Tank is saying?
-No. I just -- no.
I was seeing where that
was going.
No, let´s just watch the --
let´s watch the Tank.
-All right.
Let´s hear Tank talking.
[ Dog growling ]
-I love you.
I love you.
[ Dog growls "I love you" ]
[ Audience awws ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why -- what --
I mean, I feel like --
-Yes, yes, they´re clapping!
-Why?
I feel like you
should retire and let --
-I know.
-Tank should be the breadwinner.
-I know! I know!
-How is Tank not on TV?
He´s the "I love you" dog.
-I don´t know, it´s just crazy.
She needs her own
YouTube channel or something.
That´s -- that happened.
That´s real.
-How do you -- by the way,
because -- and I don´t want
to judge you, but I --
like, what made you think that
that would work?
[ Laughter ]
Because I have a dog too,
and I never said, "You know,
I´m gonna try to get it to say
´I love you´ back."
But you were in a situation
where it worked.
-She -- she makes these noises.
-Mm-hmm.
-She makes kind of noises
like -- like you heard.
And kind of, if you say
a word before it,
it sounds like that´s
what she´s saying.
So, if you say, like, "hello,"
it sounds like she´s saying,
"ewwo."
[ Laughter ]
And there was this time
where I was upstairs
and she peed on my friend´s rug.
You know, so we put her away.
-Yeah.
-And -- and then I left,
you know, but the dog
was alone in the room.
And apparently it sounded like
she was saying "I´m --
I´m sorry."
My friend was so,
like, freaked out.
And she was like, "The dog´s in
there going ´I´m sorry!
[ Laughter ]
I´m sor-Ry!´"
-You are --
-And she was so flipped out.
And -- anyway.
-There are so many things there
that make you the world´s
worst house guest.
-Yeah.
-You bring your dog.
-I know.
-It pisses on a rug.
Then you´re like,
"I´m gonna take off.
By the way, she talks."
-Oh, I know.
[ Laughter ]
I know. I know.
I did get a new rug.
-Oh, that´s very nice.
-And I cleaned it.
-Oh, that was -- you --
-It was a small rug.
-That seems like you did
two things that are redundant.
-The dog peed.
-I feel like, either clean
the rug or got a new one.
-Yeah.
-But get a new one
and clean one --
-I did both.
I tried to.
-Now I take it back.
You´re the world´s best
house guest.
-Yeah.
Neither one worked very well.
-Another thing we --
I gave you a hard time about
before, and I want to apologize,
is that you admitted to us that
on your acting resumé,
on your headshot,
your special skill, you listed
that driving was
a special skill.
-I did.
-You thought that that would
separate you from the pack
´cause they would say,
"We´re down to two actresses,
but only one of them drives."
[ Laughter ]
So, but then -- and I thought
that was, you know,
pretty exceptional,
that you would think that
that was worth noting.
But you also, you had another
time, you wrote,
as a special skill,
that you could run
long distances.
[ Laughter ]
Is that true?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No. I don´t --
and I was reminded of that.
-It clearly was on there.
-Yes.
And I was remind--
-So, you can´t even do it.
-No.
-Wow.
-No, I mean -- like most people,
I can run short distances,
particularly if I´m
uncomfortable or scared.
-Okay. Got it.
-You know.
-Again, not a special skill.
[ Laughter ]
Or even -- or even a skill.
-No.
I do not know --
-"I run when I´m scared."
"Oh, wow.
Did you go to school for that?"
-Right.
Yeah. I don´t know.
I was -- I just remembered
that backstage, I had --
I can´t remember doing that.
-What kind of part did you think
that would be helpful for?
-I don´t know.
I mean, I imagine if they were
remaking, like, "Marathon Man"
or something like that.
-But even then,
I would like to point out,
and you should know this, too.
Because in movies,
you don´t have to show all
of the running.
You know, you just run
a little bit and then
they edit it together
and it looks like --
You run a little bit here,
and then they cut to you running
somewhere else and as
a viewer you go, "Wow,
they ran a long way."
But an actor --
[ Laughter ]
-My God.
Maybe -- I don´t know what.
I mean, like, that they thought,
you know, "She has endurance.
She can go the distance."
-Oh, I see.
-She can work long days.
We´re not going to make her run,
but she has --
-She has endurance.
[ Light laughter ]
-And obviously, it´s worked.
You´ve been very successful.
-I mean, yeah, in some way.
-But, because they´re like --
I mean, they´re sort of --
I think it´s just, someone looks
and goes, "Oh."
-Maybe that was
in theatre school.
Maybe I still was
in theatre school coming up
with things that I thought
big Hollywood people would like,
like driving and --
long-distance running.
-It feels like, then we should
blame your theatre school that
didn´t teach you those
weren´t important things.
I think what you wanted them
to know was, "Look, I can drive,
but if there isn´t a car,
I could also run there."
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What was I thinking?
And also, when --
when did I say that out loud,
in public?
Then it was on the Internet,
you know what I mean?
-Yeah, ´cause we -- our
researchers found in real life.
But you put it there,
and then instead of just burying
the memory you then,
at some point, admitted it.
-Exactly.
-You know, I think you´re,
at your core,
a very honest person.
And no matter how much you like
to hide things, you eventually
admit that you talked to
your dog until it told you
that it loved you.
-I think you´re right.
I think there´s some truth
to that.
-And -- this is very exciting.
You guys are gonna do
a seventh season.
You´re back to work now.
-Yes.
-Which is just thrilling.
-Yeah.
-And -- we were
talking backstage.
Not only is that an
incredible accomplishment,
to be on seven years.
But, at the very least,
it means you´re gonna come back
here for a sixth time.
And I´m just so happy
in advance to have you back.
-Oh, what a pleasure.
[ Laughter ]
-I´m sure we´ll have more
talking dog videos.
Oh, yeah. by the way,
the next time you come,
it´s got to be, like,
a full sentence.
-Okay.
-I mean, like, I know
"I love you" is a full sentence,
but, like, something really --
-Okay, I´ll work on it.
-A shopping list.
I want you to say, "I´m going
to the grocery store.
Do you need anything?"
-Okay.
And I want Tank to say
at least four --
"Aluminum foil!"
[ Laughter ]
-Give it up, everybody,
for Taylor Schilling!